the Joe Rogan experience we just found
out like today yesterday like what
teachers our kids have you know I mean
it's like there's the whole like
cultural parents circle of knowing who's
teach which teachers you want and which
ones you don't and there is so it's like
I'm not gonna go into whether we got
what we wanted or not but it's like the
[ __ ] drama behind it is it's hilarity
to me it's like it's such a it's such a
like whoa like you know they did is
they're abuse going on or what you know
and Welling teachers a little more
strict than the others in my day my
parents would have said like that's the
teacher we want nowadays it's almost
like the opposite in old days my mom
would be like that's the stricter
teacher yeah I put them in that class
it's put them in that class because
that's the one that's not gonna take any
[ __ ] and that's the one is gonna get you
know tell make sure he knows and people
aren't gonna take [ __ ] from him and like
you know what I mean that's I I
understand that mentality you nowadays
it's almost the flip like all that
teachers like she's just so so abrasive
channeling it's like well what does she
do well she's raised her voice to the
kid that was what was the kid doing he
was [ __ ] losing his mind in classes
so the teacher raised their voices on
you know it's just give a general
example here but well I was hilarious we
got paddled yeah paddled at school I got
in a fight with a kid named Preston
banks we duked it out well no we'll I
got paddle I was like [ __ ] I lived there
from 11 to 13 so somewhere in that range
they [ __ ] whack mean there was this
Florida floor yeah yeah Florida they
used to be a lot of powder you this dude
had a paddle like an actual wooden
paddle and me and this kid got and that
this I remember thinking even though
it's probably like 11 or 12 or whatever
I was when I got in a fight with this
kid I realized this kid had been like
badly burned when he was young
and we were you know we're in school
together and he was like missing part of
his ear and his his neck was all [ __ ]
up and I was thinking like oh this guy
like he's not doing so well like this is
it made me realize like we got into this
little scrap over nothing because it
just he wasn't doing so well and I
didn't realize that until I was in the
principal's office with them in the
fight like we couldn't fight in front of
principal that was the authority figure
we were both like subdued
but I was realizing when I was around in
school but this isn't a mean guy he's a
sad guy like he's a guy that just didn't
get any love and he feels like he got
ripped off by life because he got burned
when he was a little kid for sure and it
made me think like it changed the way I
looked at people with the one little
argument and fight with someone kid and
then getting paddled getting power just
cemented it like wow there was stamp on
it I don't agree with it you know and
the guy didn't hurt me he didn't try to
hurt me and try to hurt the other dude
either but he definitely paddled us used
to be a legal thing put a sting on it
man you know I mean that's what we grew
up with you guys I got spanked is that
good I think I think there's appropriate
time in place I really do yeah I don't
know about that that's different cuz I
have two girls and I've never I've never
spanked my kids I don't think that's
like threatened to but I've never had to
actually commit and do it so I don't
know ya know it's it seems like it might
not be the right and even with a boy I'm
talking about that physical justice for
me she would be a rare thing let me give
you an example of when like a time in my
life when I definitely deserved physical
justice and guy my father you know he
talked bob was using guns when I was
very young we'd go out and shoot and
like not hunt necessarily but he'd take
us out and shooting mountains out in the
Manjula stores back in the day and like
[ __ ] I had a very good gun education
and understanding of guns and one time
when they were away I [ __ ] around with
his like pump shotgun and [ __ ]
accidentally [ __ ] loaded it and
[ __ ] bang a shot into the wall all
right this was an apartment - this
wasn't a house this was an apartment
building
now it wasn't a wall connected to in
another apartment but let's put the
possibilities that you know I mean when
they came home a few hours later that
apartment outside was surrounded by
police like the guns like they didn't
know what happened the neighbors all
called cops didn't they heard a shotgun
but so after they all settled it down
and I got my ass [ __ ] kicked that
last that knife on my father you mean
and
you know some people nowadays would say
that's [ __ ] rough but no I [ __ ]
could have [ __ ] killed a human being
easily I just you need to sometimes know
like okay this is because what you just
did
could have wound you up in [ __ ] the
penitentiary for the rest of your life
so an ass-kicking doesn't seem as
extreme as you think when you put it in
the balance of that so when you're
getting to like a level of that I think
especially for a boy you know I mean I
don't know if I then if a girl was going
that wild I mean I would encourage the
mom to throw the baby I mean the dad
can't throw that beating you know it'd
be a little rough but I think there's a
time and a place where like hey see if
you're gonna stop and here are you you
got to let them know here's this will be
the rest of your life yeah if you keep
down this path that's it's got to be
that extreme to me for it to be a
beating nowadays when I was young a
beating could come from talking back
right at least a smack in the face yeah
well that's you know a shoe just a
little my fear was mom after like 13 mom
stopped using the hands cuz you know it
didn't you know I had a groaner she's my
mom was little my mom was little I was a
little woman like four foot eleven five
foot tops just throwing [ __ ] oh yeah so
after a while I was like it went from it
went from the hands to like stirring
spoons and [ __ ] and then one still
started breaking it became shoes and and
like you know whatever else broomstick
and then it became like with your
[ __ ] father gets off my mom might
have like gently smack me upside the
head gently like never like a real like
wound no my mom was a Brooklyn lady like
she might have been like we doing stupid
tried to never drop me mom I remember
being like 9 or 10 and moms chasing me
down the block Oh catching me oh yeah
yeah so we're happy the worst had
happened my mom was not chasing me she'd
be like you're coming home eventually
dummy
one wasn't that mean she wasn't having
it not all word oh yeah my mom would
have never chased me she'd be like I'm
not playing your games little but she
was fast she was good she caught you
beat your ass for fun your friends so
rough when you're a young boy and you're
trying to be cool it's like the most
embarrassing like any day you could just
trip on your own dick and fall faces do
it fence like a [ __ ] [ __ ] just so
goofy
I think it actually made some of my
friends at the time understand me a
little bit differently do like oh wow
dude all right get you now we understand
kind of your whole thing like your
stielike your yeah you guys are nuts
[Applause]